[Applause]
[Music]
in Europe there are many places where
ethnic and nationalist issues are taken
with a grain of salt that is to say they
are lived out with particular intensity
practically at the surface however there
is one region that stands out above all
others of course we're talking about the
Balkans a region that in the 1990s
experienced firsthand the cruelty
senselessness and horror of a merciless
Civil War in the heart of Europe in a
past video here on visualpolitik that
I'll link for you in the description we
told you many more details about this
conflict but what matters the most to us
in this video is that one of its last
military size was the struggle that
pitted the Federal Republic of
Yugoslavia now Serbia against the ethnic
Albanian kosovar separatists this
confrontation ended in 1999 after NATO
intervened with an aerial bombing
campaign against sloboden's milho Civics
Yugoslavia he was a guy who by the way
ended his life in a prison in the Dutch
city of the Hague while being tried for
war crimes by the internet National
criminal Tribunal for the former
Yugoslavia a body created by the United
Nations to try war crimes from the
Yugoslav conflict the fact is that
although the war ended the ethnic and
political conflict went on and the truth
is that it has done so right up to this
day
the Kosovo war ended with a treaty the
kuminovo treaty which in order to pacify
the terrain gave way to a deployment of
international troops but did not include
anything resembling Independence for
Kosovo despite this the kosovars
ultimately declared their independence
unilaterally and the establishment of
the Republic of Kosovo occurred just a
few years later in 2008 since then
relations between Serbia and Kosovo have
been colder than a Canadian winter of
course the Republic of Kosovo is not
recognized by Serbia which continues to
claim full sovereignty over the
territory but to belgrade's Misfortune
it is recognized by about a hundred
member states of the United Nations
including the American superpower the
United States of America and also by 22
of the 27 states of the European Union
[Music]
foreign
this basically means that much of the
developed world and the vast majority of
the Western World sees the Republic of
Kosovo as a sovereign state which has
meant that Serbia's hand and feet are
tied when it comes to acting against
kosovar Independence now these guys are
stubborn
[Music]
far from giving up belgrade's aspiration
has always been is and seems likely to
remain to regain sovereignty over Kosovo
by any means necessary and you know what
as unrealistic as this may seem to us
the truth is that this position has
serious implications for example every
time the kosovars announced some measure
however trivial or silly it may seem to
promote disconnection or disengagement
with the Serbian State suddenly tension
flares up and things get hot again this
tension is particularly intense in the
region you see on the screen known as
North Kosovo an area made up of four
municipalities in which ethnic serbs are
in the majority and pay attention
because a little further on we will see
why this region is key to understanding
the conflict but I can already tell you
that we are talking about an area where
you will see practically nothing to do
with independent Kosovo because in these
four municipalities most of the
inhabitants do not identify with the
Republic of Kosovo or its government but
wish to remain part of Serbia so how
does the Serbian government respond to
this desire well I'm sure you can
imagine
Serbia has declared itself the protector
of ethnic serbs living in this region
within the Republic of Kosovo in a way
it's very similar to Vladimir Putin's
approach to Russian minorities in the
former Soviet States if they think the
Kosovo albanians will come to organize
life in the north and they have no right
to do so neither according to the
Brussels agreement nor according to the
will of the people I am afraid that that
will lead to a disaster Alexander vukik
president of Serbia well right at the
end of 2022 and the beginning of 2023
the tensions fled up again to very high
levels for many analysts this signals
that a future disaster could be in the
making and yes it may seem inconceivable
the ball that things could get out of
hand in the middle of Europe but given
what we've seen in Ukraine it is no
longer easy to make such assertions if
anything has become clear it is at the
worst of nightmares can become reality
the question is what is it that has
brought the conflict between Serbia and
Kosovo back into the international
Spotlight Is it feasible that a war
between these two countries will happen
again well let's take a look but before
another question are you aware that your
personal information is being sold on
the internet without your knowledge
probably not this is widespread and On
The Rise according to the annual data
breach report by the identity theft
Resource Center there were 68 more
breaches in 2021 than the previous year
but the good news is that you have the
rights to protect your privacy by asking
data Brokers to remove the information
they have about you bad news is that
that would take you years to do it
manually but wait because all is not
lost in cogney our sponsor today will
help you solve this problem in three
easy steps create an account and enter
your data grant them the rights to work
for you they will contact the data
Brokers on your behalf to request the
deletion of your personal data relax and
see how they work they will handle any
objections from the data Brokers and
keep you informed of their progress
every step of the way and the best of
all the first 100 people to use the code
politic en at the link below will get 20
off Incognito so don't miss this
opportunity
[Music]
a change of letters
let's see if I were to say that the
biggest political military tensions in
years between the serbs and kosovars
have been caused by a change in car
license plates how would you feel about
that well guess what I'm not
exaggerating at all it was a change in
vehicle registrations by the Kosovo
government that has once again sparked a
fierce ethnic and political
confrontation between the two
territories or rather it was the final
straw
foreign
started in July 2022 the Kosovo
government under Albin curti announced a
plan to implement a change that had been
pending for more than a decade the end
of Serbian vehicle registration in
Kosovo the plan included a deadline for
changing the Serbian license plates of
vehicles to Kosovo license plates and a
phased implementation schedule it was a
timeline that included an initial
warning period a period of sanctions and
finally the forced imposition of the new
license plates which included a ban on
circulation or even the confiscation of
vehicles that did not comply with the
rule not only that it was also announced
that Serbian citizens would have to
handle entry and exit documents when
entering or leaving Kosovo
well as you can easily imagine these
measures did not sit well at all with
the kosovars of the north who remember
are mostly ethnic serbs who feel
themselves to be Serbian citizens
for many people having to obtain
documents in order to leave or enter
Kosovo was tantamount to becoming
second-class citizens marginalized and
singled out and the same goes for the
new kosovar license plates since for
these ethnic serps using license plates
on their cars from a state that for them
does not exist and was created against
their will is simply unacceptable and
yes it may seem like an overreaction to
you but I assure you that in these
territories national identity is
something experienced very intensely so
of course they were not going to just
stand idly by check it out
in response Serb kosovar groups in July
2022 erected barricades in North Kosovo
and declared themselves unsubmissive to
the authorities it was a reaction that
forced the intervention by NATO forces
in Kosovo the K4 which were redeployed
to patrol the streets and ensure
security while the cost of our police
closed the Border
in short due to some license plates and
a few papers the mess kicked off again
and what can I say this is not an easy
situation by any means whatever your
opinion about the independence of Kosovo
it is relatively easy to understand from
a political social and cultural point of
view the agar of the people who have
always lived in that region and who do
not feel part of the new state that has
incorporated them but let's not get
sidetracked
[Music]
the fact is that after a lot of back and
forth agreements agreement attempts
disagreements political interventions
and appeals from the European Union and
the United States do you know what
happened in the end well in November
2022 the Kosovo government said that the
license plates transition would be done
and that the phased plan would be
implemented between November 2022 and
April 2023 so what happened next well it
was only a matter of time Kosovo serbs
continue Mass resignations from State
institutions Kosovo served police
officials who resigned from the police
over the weekend as part of a mass
resignation alongside MPS Mayors
judicial officials have continued
resigning with officers handing over
their weapons and cuffs of course these
events have not gone unnoticed in Serbia
which has seen the opportunity to try to
destabilize the kosovar authorities at
least in the north part of the
self-proclaimed Republic how did they do
it take a look the state of Serbia says
and we say that we will take care of
them the resigned officials that's a new
50 or 60 million Euros for us we will do
it all Alexander president of Serbia you
know politics now Serbia has officials
in Kosovo again but that's not all in
the weeks that followed things have only
gotten worse
after ethnic serbs began to resign from
kosovo's state-linked institutions
ethnic tensions at the street level soon
emerged 10th of December 2022 Kosovo
serbs block road to main border
crossings in volatile North they were
outraged over the arrest of an ethnic
Serb former police officer who is
suspected of being involved in recent
attacks on Kosovo police officers and so
it continues in December 2022 the serbs
announced that they were putting their
army on alert the level of Readiness
prior to the war well now that we all
know more or less what has happened in
recent months to make Kosovo and Serbia
deserve a whole video on visualpolitik
the question we can ask ourselves now is
is there really a chance of seeing
another war in Europe in the short to
medium term could Serbia end up
attacking Kosovo what are the chances of
a conflict breaking out between these
two countries and what are the chances
that it will end up not happening well
let's find out
the next war in Europe
the war in Ukraine has suddenly awakened
the whole of Europe from a sweet dream
in which he had been immersed for
several decades believing that another
war on the ELD continent was a
completely impossible scenario now of
course that sentiment has changed and
along with Ukraine probably the other
big hot spot in European geopolitics is
the Balkans particularly the Western
Balkans in fact the thought of a new
conflict in this region is not so
far-fetched now is it something for
which there is an immediate risk if so
what kind of a War or conflict are we
talking about well answering these
questions with blunt answers would be
almost like guessing the future and you
know that on visualpolitik we are not
big fans of crystal balls but what we
can do is tell you the reasons why and
why not a military clash between Serbia
and Kosovo could end up taking place and
what would eventuate if something like
that were to happen
[Music]
on the yes side so the possibility of a
military conflict the first thing to
keep in mind is that Serbia has already
been making significant defense
Investments for many years that are
serving to improve its military
capability to give you an idea spending
in 2018 was almost double that of three
years earlier and in 2022 it invested
some 1 billion euros in new equipment
alone
[Music]
yes okay one billion to some may seem
like a small amount for a country that
has NATO protecting its great adversary
but what is striking is the trend they
have adopted in recent years Serbia is
on a shopping spree for weapons and its
neighbors don't like it between 2015 and
2021 Serbia's defense spending jumped by
some 70 to 1.4 billion a year Russia and
Belarus have given it 10 MiG-29 Jets
Russia has given it 30 tanks and armored
personnel carriers and sold it an air
defense system it has bought Chinese
armored drones Russian helicopters and a
French surface-to-air missile system
evidently more weapons and more
ethnopolitical tensions could end up
leading to one thing a miscalculation
mistakes that in such tense environments
can be caused by the most absurd details
and take note because that is precisely
what is in abundance here off-duty
Kosovo Soldier suspected of wounding two
local serbs police said both victims age
11 and 21 were taken to hospital and
their injuries were not life-threatening
police said the suspect was 33 years old
now does this mean that another war
between Serbia and Kosovo is just a
matter of time no of course not not at
all but it does contribute to the
festering of ethnic tensions and who
knows it could also trigger a small
military Skirmish or two in the Border
areas so why are we saying or why do we
think that it's very unlikely that
Serbia and Kosovo will become the scene
of another war in Europe at least in the
short term well we have several reasons
to think this way and the first one is
more than obvious the presidents of NATO
forces the K4
since the end of the Serbian Kosovo war
in 1999 some 4 000 NATO troops have been
stationed in Kosovo troops whose
presence alone serves to deter any
large-scale Serbian attack because
naturally in the end if an invasion
attempt were to take place not only
Kosovo but also NATO troops would be
attacked so the reaction could be
enormously costly for Serbia and believe
me nobody in Belgrade wants to see
images again that are already part of
the past
however if you want more concrete
indications pay attention to these
headlines 10 for December 2022 Serbia to
ask NATO to deploy Serb police police in
Kosovo 8th of January 2023 NATO declined
Serbia's request to deploy its troops in
Kosovo think about it for a moment
unless it was a twisted and bizarre Ploy
by the Serbian government isn't it a bit
strange to ask NATO's permission to
deploy your forces in a territory you
consider your own if you were really
thinking of invading it
[Applause]
foreign
of course from the Serbian point of view
the territory of Kosovo is as much
Serbia as Belgrade itself so asking NATO
for permission to deploy Serbian forces
and what's more respecting their refusal
is quite revealing therefore and despite
all the headlines we can find it does
not seem at all likely that the serbs
are even thinking of angering NATO with
outbursts in the military field and that
my friends is key but you know what this
is not the only argument we can find to
dismiss the Serbian invasion you see not
a long time ago on visualpolitik we told
you all about the peculiar relationship
that Serbia has with the European Union
if you haven't seen that video well you
can find that link in the description so
in a nutshell Serbia is one of the seven
states that maintain the status of an
official candidate for full membership
into the European Union and although for
years they have been showing little or
no effort to make the reforms that would
allow accession the fact is that their
candidate status is on the table a
status that brings significant benefits
[Music]
thanks to being considered an official
candidate to join the European Club
Serbia enjoys significant commercial
advantages and also economic aid here
are just two facts more than 60 of
exports and between 55 and 59 of imports
of the Serbian economy are directed to
or originate from the European Union not
only that 60 to 80 of all foreign direct
investment that has come to Serbia since
2010 is also European
[Music]
now why are we telling you this well do
you remember what we told you at the
beginning of the video about the
recognition of Kosovo as a sovereign and
independent state by the vast majority
of European nations that's just it if
Serbia were to overstep The Mark with
Kosovo its status as a candidate for EU
membership would be jeopardized or even
canceled and with that they could kiss
goodbye to all the advantages that this
status entails
foreign and of course they would also
risk suffocating International sanctions
such as those currently being
implemented against Russia believe me
when I say that in a country as
economically dependent on the European
Union as Serbia is that could be very
devastating this is something we've
already told you the West's response to
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is serving
and will surely serve in the future as a
warning to many countries with
militaristic aspirations to think twice
[Music]
in addition to make matters worse
Serbia's only major unmitigated support
for Kosovo is precisely Russia and well
let's just say that with the economic
and Military attrition that Putin's
country is suffering they are not going
to be able to lend a hand to Serbia
either now or for a long time to come so
as you can see ethnopolitical and even
military tensions have been are and seem
to continue to be the way Serbia and
Kosovo relate to each other but it does
not seem that blood is about to be shed
but now it's your turn do you think
Kosovo and Serbia will go to war again
in the future how do you think the
International Community would react in
such a case would they act the same more
actively or more passively than they did
with Ukraine leave us your opinion Below
in the comments and you know if you like
this video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to our channel so you don't
miss any future videos once again thank
you for watching all the best see you
next time
[Music]